hey guys and welcome to a brand new
video uh today I'm going to be doing
something I have never done before and
that is a comparison video uh we're
going to be comparing today is using the
enchantment spells uh determining what
enchantment level is the most cost
effective cuz some of them are
profitable some of them are break even
and some of them are really good magic
experience per hour uh so we're going to
go over both the level two three four
and five enchantment if you can't get to
level two uh this video is not for you
uh and you might notice my voice is
terrible once again I did get sick so
often but I do apologize uh I did about
two and a half hours of singing in my
room alone uh to try to warm up my voice
so I hope you guys can understand and
let's get started okay so to start off
we are going to do the Jade amulets
because they are the lowest level well
not the lowest but they are the level
two enchantment uh so we'll take off the
Jade amulets which we did buy for 401
and 250 Cosmic runes and uh for this you
will need an air staff luckily for all
these enchantments that there is a staff
that can pretty much Safeguard all your
runes except for the cosmic Rune of
course okay so it's pretty simple all
you're going to do is just start using
the enchantments on the necklaces
luckily for the new silver jewelry it
does actually provide a different uh
image for when you've Enchanted the
necklace uh cuz before it was extremely
annoying uh you would never know which
necklace you were on uh we'll get that
open so you can see the experience rates
afterwards we're going to do all the
experience rates first and then we'll
calculate the uh profit afterwards okay
so we're just finishing up with this
inventory uh an inventory takes about a
minute uh so we're going to go ahead and
do all of these just to get an accurate
experience rate uh but 72 uh is pretty
good I think it'll probably drop down
closer to 60 but we'll continue doing
this and we'll be back in a minute okay
guys we're just finishing up the last
seven uh now it looks like the XP rates
is actually closer to 55k I was at 58k
but then a turnament recorder so I'd say
about 55k an hour uh Magic experience
which is pretty good for level two uh
enchant uh yeah there we go 55k and
we'll go ahead and keep these for now
and we'll sell them all at the end okay
so the next step up is the topaz amulet
uh 250 we got those um 750 chaos runes
now for the topaz amulet you're going to
need a staff of fire which again is very
easily obtainable okay so we're going to
start off and do another 10 minutes of
this I guess we might as well CHS the
cosmic runes at the bottom because we're
needing those close and anyway let's
start enchanting these we're making
amulet burning amulet
sorry and we should be getting even more
experience hour CU every cast we're
getting 59 as opposed to 37 I believe
the other one was uh so already we
jumped up to over 100k an hour uh again
I doubt it'll stay that high but we'll
probably rest down around 70 or 80k uh
which is excellent for well what is this
enchantment level 49 to do this uh very
good it is Click intensive of course but
now what are you going to do okay after
the first inventory it looks like we got
101k per hour at saying that's probably
not accurate but anyway we'll go ahead
and do all these uh amulet 250 and come
back with the result okay we're just
finishing up the last amulet here it
looks like we're getting about 90k
experience per hour again it dropped
about about 5k when I went to start the
recorder uh but still 90k is pretty good
we've done all
250 uh so 0k an hour from the topaz
amulets I feel like these might be the
most efficient to go with but we'll see
uh so we got 250 burning amulets now
okay so for the level four enchant you
can only enchant diamond jewelry uh so
we picked the diamond amulet you could
also do uh the diamond ring to make into
Ring of Life but the amulets uh trade a
little bit more uh so we're going to do
the diamond amulet make them into Amulet
of power okay so once again we've reset
our experience tracker going to go ahead
and start using the level four enchant
now okay I already [__] it up now um
You may notice I actually have OS Buddy
Pro right now and it's actually free for
the weekend uh so normally this feature
and this nice feature of having the
green overlay is not there but currently
it is so this is partly why I'm making a
video
actually uh so yeah this is one of os
bu's more useful features I would say
anyway um already [__] stuff up a bit
looks like it's
about maybe 115 to
120 a [__] see I'm already it's already
more difficult even with the green
overlay um you can't really see the
difference in the amulet it looks the
exact same so without this it can be a
bit of a pain in the ass so I would
expect a bit lower experience rates uh
but for this I'm guessing maybe around
105 or something like that uh so we'll
just finish up the inventory since we're
kind of getting close again 10 minutes
for each of these not very long but it
is kind of Click intensive so once you
find the most profitable or most
efficient amul I would just stick with
that one uh because can't kind hurt your
hands after a while but 100K and I don't
think we're going to lose very much on
this either or we may even profit it's
pretty good and the level three enchant
spell level 57 so still not extremely
high level uh but yeah anyway let's do
all 250 and we'll be back in a minute
okay so it looks like enchanting the
level four enchant is about 100K an hour
uh which is I guess 15 or 10K more than
the level three enchant and once again I
don't think we're actually lose much on
this enchantment uh so that's pretty
nice so 100K per hour for the level four
enchant okay so for the level five
enchant you're going to want the mud
battle staff equipped we cover all the
cost the runes once again uh we have 250
Cosmic runes well 270 but [__] it and
we'll start enchanting the amulets um
now I'm not going to do the uh zenite
and um Onyx amulets because they're just
way too damn expensive no one in the
right mind is going to have an hour's
worth of um zenite or onx jewelry it's
just not realistic so looks like on the
level five enchant I'm powering up to
about 160k an hour uh which which I
don't think we'll keep that high at all
uh but we could probably get up to 130
or maybe even 140 if we're paying
attention um but yeah so I'm not sure
this is the one where I'm you might lose
money on uh really depending on the
prices we'll definitely check this
afterwards but we'll just finish off
this
inventory 150k um it really comes down
to how quickly you can click can make a
huge difference uh right now I kind of
have 10 kned so it's a little
challenging but um anyway looks like
about 150 we'll go ahead and do the 250
and be back in a minute
okay we're just finishing up the dragon
Stones amulet Dragon Stone amulet uh
looks like 130k an hour is what you
could expect uh of course this is a lot
more expensive than the other three
enchantments so it's not as cost
effective by any means but there you go
130k uh per hour you could assume to get
uh when you're enchanting Dragon Stones
okay so now we have all four amulets and
we're in the grand exchange we're going
to go ahead and sell them off uh so to
start off we'll do the ulet of chemistry
looks like this is selling for about 1K
uh which is actually pretty decent
profit uh 250k from that uh burning
amulet next burning amulet is selling
for
1617 uh so I think we'll profit on that
one as well
1616 for and 5K from that one um The
Well Amulet of power is selling for 2650
and last up the Amulet of Glory uh
hopefully should sell the quickest I
would assume but who knows is selling
for 174
80 okay so for 4.3 mil we're selling
those four interested to see if we're
going to lose money on that or not uh so
yeah we'll wait for these to sell off
and we'll be back with the profit and
the XP rate all right guys so now for
the part you've all been waiting for the
comparison uh so to start off the level
two enchant we use on the Jade amulet uh
giv us 60k magic experience per hour uh
which isn't bad but I don't think I
would do this just to train magic but we
did get about 700k uh profit have we
done this for the hour of course uh
surprisingly these amulets bought sold
the quickest of the four uh which kind
of surprised me honestly um for the
level three enchant we got 90k magic
experience per hour uh which is pretty
good and 1.2 mil coins had we done it
for the hour uh these did take a little
bit longer to buy but they sold right
away uh but 1.2 mil 90k magic experience
that really good for like a LEL 40 or 50
spell next up we have the uh Diamond
amulets we did amulets all the way
through because they are the most used
and uh provided the most consistent
profit because other uh jewelry pieces
had a better margin but they wouldn't
buy very quick so the level four enchant
got us 100K magic experience per hour
and 170k GP per hour so not a whole lot
um but for your value it's actually
pretty good 100K magic experience per
hour and the cost of the amulet is not
that high only like 2 or
3K uh now for the level five enchant we
got 130k magic experience per hour which
is great but 1.5 mil have we done it for
the full hour uh main drawback here is
buying enough amulets to last an hour uh
would have
cost somewhere in the range of 30 to 40
mil maybe a bit less but quite a bit
that being said uh they sold off very
quickly and um provided a really really
good profit margin and yeah so that's
the comparison I hope you enjoyed and
let's go uh see if my stuff is
sold okay so we are done and everything
I sold so in total we did make 600k um
off of all the amulets of course two of
the four we're in very good GP per hour
but of course we wanted to test them all
uh the G8 amulets we got a 470 GP margin
on each one uh the topaz amulet were
835 the diamond amulet only 118 on each
one and the dragon Stone amulet are was
984 so 600k in profit not bad uh if you
continue to do the dragon Stone ulet you
could have made 1.5 mil and 130k Magic
experience per hour which is extremely
good of course you can't do this hours
on end even doing it for 1 hour it
probably take a day of preparation but
still if you have the money and you have
the time it's definitely a good method
to do all right hope you guys enjoyed
and I will see you guys in the next
video
[Music]